[Music]  ladies and gentlemen the wife of the  attorney general of the united states  martha mitchell  you are the first person to publicly  accuse the president for the watergate  break-in  are you crazy  i'm a southern woman we speak our minds  we talk i never stop talking i bet your  husband just loves that he takes it in  stride  [Music]  the loudmouth wife of his martha was  becoming too much of a liability  you want to know the truth  there's no conspiracy hiding in the  shadows  a lot of women your age suffer from  paranoid episodes  [Music]  nobody gives a damn what you think  miss mitchell why risk your husband's  position  because it's the truth  see  [Music]  you